I've never really had it and it smells
like sawdust burgers are delicious sadly
they're not good for us and they're not
good for the environment you may have
heard of something called the impossible
burger it is supposed to be the closest
thing to a real meat it bleeds it tastes
like a hamburger but this is made of
plant protein you can get it in
restaurant it's kind of expensive so I
wanted to see if there was a comparable
recipe that I could make at home that
would taste close-ish to an impossible
burger this is the I'm possible burger
from a website called planted 365 I'm
gonna try and make this burger and then
I'm gonna have my friend Ari come in
later and see how it compares to one
from a restaurant the thing about these
burgers is that they bleed like a real
hamburger which is very cool and almost
terrifying and the way that they bleed a
lot of the time is with beets something
so ugly on the outside is beautiful on
the inside
OOP they look like jewels I also have
ruined my hands I'm gonna grate these
suckers
whoa mama Mia look at this oh there's a
lot more beats than I need okay so I've
got one cup of grated beets and this is
gonna make my burgers real juicy and
bleed like an animal burger which is
cool
I think mushrooms are really cool
because it's just making food out of
something that's kind of gross it's like
mold that's okay to eat and that is very
cool to me okay now the recipe says to
saute the mushrooms until they're tender
and brown so I'm going to do that
because I can read so my mushrooms are
looking brown and tender I don't know
about yours but these these are looking
good so I'm gonna take them off the heat
put them in my little Bowl there we go
and now we're just gonna combine this
and a bunch of other stuff into a food
processor I don't know if it's gonna
taste like an impossible burger just
because it is like a very basic recipe
but I do think it's gonna make a really
interesting vegetarian burger okay so
we've got our mushrooms here we got
beets baby a lot of tempeh here and then
we're gonna add a cup of sticky rice
this is getting full 1/4 cup of oats for
a little I guess texture a little
gristle we're gonna do one tablespoon of
nutritional yeast I've never really had
it and it smells like sawdust but I know
that it is like a common vegan
replacement for cheese
there's my TV speed beautiful 1/2
teaspoon of liquid smoke I'm just gonna
do a little drip ohs we got a little bit
so you gotta have seasonings burgers
don't need a lot of seasoning but we're
trying to replicate that so we need a
lot of seasoning we got red pepper
flakes
we got pepper we got a little bit of
onion powder smells like an everything
bagel which I'm into okay let's pulse
this baby
[Applause]
the texture is shockingly like me look
at that okay I'm just gonna do a little
bit more I've got my mixture here and
I'm just gonna like form them into
little burger patties okay that was good
that was like a burger I don't know
about you but that was like a burger to
me it's gonna be difficult to know how
it's gonna taste it until we cook it so
let's cook it I guess that's a sizzle
there's certainly a sizzle happening I
have no patience when it comes to this
whenever it's like put it down and don't
touch it for five minutes I'm like
there's no way I can do that we'll start
this other one as well you know in case
something terrible happens for this one
it is cooking so that's good well now
that's an interesting phenomenon not
what I expected certainly the liquid
smoke makes it smell like a burger
cooking it's like a suggestion of a
burger I'm pretty proud of it honestly
it's beautiful I mean beauty is in the
eye of the beholder but I think it looks
pretty good this one we don't need to
put we just don't pay attention to this
one this one is a tester I've learned
this one is my beauty my son my child
now that doesn't that look nice now I'm
gonna address this bad boy up a little
and we're gonna see how it compares to a
store-bought impossible burger it smells
all right I'd eat it can you guess which
one I made probably this one but just
because the bun tipped me off if you had
switched the buns I wouldn't be able to
tell very interesting I like the look of
it
do you want to try yes I tried it
classic first okay so yeah it looks like
a plant burger beautiful that's like
brown inside
mmm-hmm tastes like a real burger to me
yeah you know don't get that don't you
tell me you're still the one that I
toiled and slaved over over yeah how
long does it take you to make this
that's not really that hard
I imagine me with like a mortar and
pestle like grinding the bolts
shall we see this cross-section Oh yours
looks bloody like a bunch of red hmm use
a softer and I am very soft this doesn't
taste like meat but I do really enjoy
the flavor of the patty and how the
vegetables come through more do you
think it's better than a classical
veggie burger yes
I mean I'm eating the whole thing so I
think I like it because I am trying to
imitate something that you probably
couldn't make in your kitchen by
yourself I think it's a pretty good
imitation I'm vegetarian and so when I
crave a burger I'll go out and like just
buy one but they're like 17 dollars they
are really expensive and that's on the
sides
yeah there's no sides included there you
come on fries kind of tastes like a
potato chip I'll take it load up
[Music]